[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN THAGARD: Hey,
good afternoon.
My name's Dan Thagard.
I'm the director of site
reliability and core
engineering at Magic Leap.
My team's mission
at Magic Leap is
to provide technology
solutions and services
to the rest of the organization,
to enable people to do
and perform their best work.
We're a globally
distributed team.
We provide 24/7, 365
support to our customers.
And one of the challenges that
we face as being a global team
is--
well, apart from
daylight savings,
and realizing that New
Zealand actually goes
the opposite direction than
the US when the time changes--
is to kind of maintain
a sense of team
and maintain a sense of
community and team building.
So last year, we were
casting around for ideas
for how can we do a
team building exercise.
And we landed on
the idea of, hey,
why don't we build an
app for Magic Leap One?
Now, I've got to preface this
by saying that none of us
are 3D application developers.
We're not modelers, or graphics
artists, or game designers
whatsoever.
But we are SREs, and we
know how to build and run
infrastructure, and run
it reliably at scale.
So we said, hey, wouldn't
it be really cool
if we can take the
infrastructure that we
do and work with day to day, and
be able to visualize it using
spatial computing, to be able
to actually see all the nodes,
and show the dependencies
and everything that we're
working on.
So that's what we decided to do.
That was our challenge.
We wanted to, in 24 hours, be
able to build and visualize,
using Terraform,
our infrastructure
and spatial computing.
And that's what we did.
So 24 hours later-- well,
about 30 hours, actually.
But in a day, we were able to--
with no help, no outside
help, no documentation--
just using what
our customers see,
we were able to build on-device,
having no previous Unity
experience and no previous
on [INAUDIBLE] or anything
like that.
And it was a really empowering
and joyful experience.
I can't describe
how happy that was
the first time I saw this sea
of Leapers appear on stage in 3D
in front of me.
It was kind of like my first
"Hello, world" all over again.
One of the challenges that
we faced with this was,
not having any
outside help, we had
to kind of dig within the
team, and leverage each other,
and really work
together as a team.
So I'm going to turn it
over to Anthony right now.
He's going to talk through some
of the technical challenges
that we faced as
a team as we were
trying to build
out infrastructure
using mixed reality.
ANTHONY LUCILLO: Thanks, Dan.
My name is Anthony Lucillo.
I'm a site reliability
engineer at Magic Leap,
and the technical
lead of Nebula.
We built this experience
using Unity and C#.
For the multiplayer
element, we are
using Photon, which handles the
user and room management, as
well as synchronization of
object data like position,
rotation, scale,
even custom metadata
that we're able to send.
Using Terraform and
a CI/CD pipeline,
we deployed the necessary back
end components, Google Cloud
Functions and Google
Cloud Storage.
This allowed us to
pull Terraform state
data, which we then parse and
visualize in mixed reality.
There is so much more that
you can do than simply
reading a Terraform state file.
Imagine, you could make
changes in real time
with Terraform in mixed reality,
query near-live metadata
to facilitate tasks like
architecture reviews, cost
analysis, and system
health monitoring.
You can even customize
your war rooms
with dashboards,
comms channels, and
whatever other
useful information
you could fill the room with.
And because this
is collaborative,
you would all see the exact
same thing in that war room.
In my opinion, the
most important part
of this experience
is making sure
that everyone sees the same
thing in the same place.
Which brings us to the most
complex and interesting problem
that we faced--
how do you make sure that every
user in the same experience
sees the same thing?
Each device is independent.
Therefore, how can multiple
users in the same experience
know everyone else's
position and orientation?
Where is the origin?
There are a few solutions
to this problem.
Our experience solves
this using image tracking.
The Magic Leap image
tracking system
uses the camera to detect
two-dimensional planar
images from a
custom-defined target set,
and continuously tracks
and updates its location
and orientation as users move
around in the real world.
This image, therefore,
becomes a point of reference,
a way for everyone to agree on
an orientation and an origin
for the room.
Now that we're through
the technical details,
let's watch a quick
video of Nebula.
[AUDIO TRADEMARK PLAYING]
And here, we're in
the-- oh, it's over.
OK.
OK, we're choosing a room.
We've got a couple Terraform
architectures to choose from.
You can drag it out
and into the room
and manipulate their position.
The red indicators
you see are what
other users in the same
experience are looking at.
And as you can see,
other users are also
able to move objects
at the same time,
and you're able to even
try to steal it from them.
And you can also move up
to it and interact with it,
because it's out there
in the real world.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Great, thanks.
Big round of applause, please,
for the team at Magic Leap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]